let's look at what a kind of democracy
zielinski is leading in Ukraine you know
he not only jailed his political
opponents very very very early on he
banned their entire political party
um you know there are so many different
you know he shut down any media that was
not controlled by him and his government
essentially so no free speech uh no no
room for any political opposition
and then he went after uh religion no
religious freedom in this country he
shut down the second largest Christian
Church in that country uh and for for
what under the guise of democracy and
freedom how how is this representative
of of the kind of democracy that that
our Founders envisioned it doesn't
So to that point you you were one of the
most outspoken anti-war congresswoman
Congress people in the country while you
served and you paid the price for it I
mean literally again Hillary was calling
you a Russian stooge or whatever
whatever they were saying about you
literally because you were anti-war so
right now with this Ukraine situation we
are not at War Congress has not declared
war but we are funding a war to over a
hundred billion dollars at this point
another 40 billion just in the in the
1.7 trillion dollar bill we're funding
the war we're giving weapons we're
giving intelligence we're training
soldiers to me that kind of sounds like
we're at War uh it essentially is a
proxy war and this is a yet another way
that this Administration and Congress
Democrats and Republicans in Congress
have once again bypassed their
constitutional responsibility if they
want to go to war with Russia which
they've made very clear that that is
what they want both directly and
verbally and also indirectly through
their actions
make your case make your case to the
American people about why you feel that
that is so important why they feel it is
in the best interest of our country and
the American people and why the American
people should be willing to pay the
price for it as you said it's already
over a hundred billion dollars uh
meanwhile you look at a lot of folks who
are still struggling and suffering uh
here at home uh both those who have been
impacted by natural disasters those in
Mississippi for example who are still
under a boiled water policy because they
don't have access to clean drinking
water that they can use for their
families I mean there are so many basic
basic challenges here that we are too
often told we just we just can't afford
it we don't have the money for it and
yet we the the people have had no say in
this hundred billion dollars that's gone
over to fund this proxy war uh with
Russia via Ukraine what to speak of the
suffering of the Ukrainian people
um
so so what do we do I think is is the
big question right at this point because
we all have great compassion for the
people of Ukraine uh what Putin did is
wrong absolutely wrong in invading
Ukraine these are not disputable things
the problem is that you we have
politicians in Washington and the Biden
Administration as well as in Congress
who even though they say they care for
the people of Ukraine are not doing what
is necessary to bring about an end to
this war instead seeking to escalate it
further and further and doing so uh
through their actions which again really
just shows their true motives true
intentions uh which is is feeding into
the military-industrial complex uh it's
not about bringing about peace because
if it were all the way back in February
and in March and in subsequent months
since they would have been supporting a
peace process rather than actively
trying to block pocket were you shocked
when zielinski gave that speech to
Congress a couple weeks ago and and in
essence said there will be no compromise
I mean it's a little odd to say and I
agree with you on the first off we at
locals we had an office in Ukraine we
had to move our guys out we've gotten
some of them to the United States but
some of them are in Macedonia right now
like I have complete sympathy for
everyone there but the guy that's in the
war shows up here and says I will not
compromise with the guy with nukes and
everyone applaud it it's like do you
know what happens when the guy with
nukes thinks he's losing
exactly exactly
um there there was so much that was
deeply disturbing about that speech and
how most members of Congress reacted
with Applause with adoration
um
treating him as though he is some some
hero or or rock star I think one of the
things that in addition to the point
that you mentioned about about we have
actively and and I I hold our leaders
responsible zelinski is going to do what
zelinski is going to do but I hold our
leaders responsible President Biden
Democrat Republican leaders in Congress
responsible for the decisions that they
have made that have put the American
people in our country at risk by
escalating this war against a
nuclear-armed power pushing us to the
brink of nuclear catastrophe with no
with no plan with no investment saying
okay well here we are good thing we went
and invested trillions of dollars in
underground bunkers for every American
citizen to go and take shelter because
we've put you in this situation they've
not done that at all if anything they've
done it for themselves but not for the
American people which leaves which
leaves us in a position of of Parish in
that scenario but the other thing in
addition to that that was so disturbing
about his speech was
how he spoke about freedom and he spoke
about democracy and he's not only
putting himself in the position as being
this champion of democracy around the
world but our own leaders have lionized
him and made this whole War about well
we have to defend democracy and freedom
in Ukraine or else democracy and freedom
in the world will be assaulted or or
attacked well let's look at what uh kind
of democracy zielinski is leading in
Ukraine you know he not only jailed his
political opponents very very very early
on he banned their entire political
party
um you know there are so many different
you know he shut down any media that was
not controlled by him and his government
essentially so no free speech uh no no
room for any political opposition
and then he went after uh religion no
religious freedom in this country he
shut down the second largest Christian
Church in that country uh and for for
what under the guise of democracy and
freedom how how is this representative
of of the kind of democracy that that
our Founders envisioned it doesn't and
so what what I what I reflected on what
I think every American should think
about is they watch this this is the guy
they have put as the figurehead of
democracy and we saw Republicans and
Democrats cheering and applauding for
this person uh who doesn't believe in
free speech doesn't believe in freedom
of religion doesn't believe in Freedom
or democracy really at all
and so we should not therefore then be
surprised if this is what they believe
democracy is
then we shouldn't be surprised at the
kinds of things that they're doing to
undermine our own freedoms here at home
and our own uh democracy here at home
because it's it's happening it's not a
question at this point and this should
be this should be alarming uh for
everybody and not surprising that this
is the the direction that they're that
they're taking which is not
representative democracy at all it's
more representative of a dictatorship or
an authoritarian government yeah and the
funny part is I don't blame zielinski
for coming here and demanding money and
demanding no compromise because why the
hell not and then you walk away with
everything you asked for so he's doing
what's what he believes is right for
himself or his party or his country and
you've got a bunch of people here that
are like oh how much can I write on that
check and exactly yeah exactly and and
that's that's the thing that that's so
crazy to me I even after that speech I
think it was a couple of days ago there
was a story that popped up where
zielinski was was basically saying that
his quote-unquote allies have no excuse
not to to send him these light armored
vehicles there's no excuse why they
aren't just sending him exactly every
single thing that he demands
that's crazy to me and it's crazy what's
even crazier than his demands though is
he knows what power he has because he
has the most powerful people in the
United States of America bowing to him
and giving him whatever he wants and
President Biden essentially seeding our
country's foreign policy decisions
to this guy
in Ukraine
um you know when people ask the
president well when when does this war
end when do we stop when is enough
enough and he says well well you know
we're in it why I don't I'm not going to
quote him directly because I don't have
the quote but he basically has said
we'll do whatever it takes we're in this
until what this is up to Putin to decide
like what what about your leadership
your responsibility as the president
United States what about the leadership
of of the head of the house the head of
the Senate from both political parties
where is their leadership and their
responsibility coming to play because
they are certainly not serving the best
interests of the American people our
security and our country with these
decisions if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of mindless
drivel check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification Bell